Pat I have been waiting for this day for
a long time no it's not the day that Pat
finally announces he's no longer vegan
no it's not the day that my chess rating
finally climbs over 450 it's the day
that CNN has started to do live
fact-checking of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is press briefings as they are happening
with graphics what a day for for nearly
2 years now I've been saying the press
corps must fact check the press
briefings the press corps must insist
that questions be answered if a question
is asked and Sarah Huckabee Sanders
doesn't answer it
the next reporter should ask the exact
same question until we get an answer and
I've also been saying if they're not
willing to do that
maybe the network's should just stop
airing the press briefings altogether
and we're gonna have an example of that
later today as well so let's go to
yesterday's press briefing Sarah
Huckabee Sanders the vile depraved
disgusting lying press secretary gives
her first press briefing in nearly a
month CNN comes out of nowhere with
graphics that pop up on the screen as
soon as Sarah Huckabee sander starts
lying and directly contradict or expose
the fact that she is telling lies so
we're gonna play one clip here in a
moment and you're gonna notice if you're
watching that as Sarah Huckabee Sanders
is talking about this climate change
report from Trump's own administration
which Trump said he doesn't believe they
immediately when she starts lying put up
the graphics that tell you the truth
just the facts not editorialized and if
you're if you're not watching I'll
describe the graphics after if you are
watching you'll actually see these on
screen let's take a look the president
certainly Leaney leading on what matters
most in this process so that's on having
clean air clean water in fact the United
States continues to be a leader on that
front
even Obama's undersecretary for science
didn't believe the radical conclusions
of the report that result release and
you have to look at the fact that this
report is based on the most extreme
model scenario
which contradicts long-established
trends modeling the climate is an
extremely go hated science that is never
exact the biggest thing that we can do
is focus on how to make sure we have the
cleanest air the cleanest water and the
president is certainly doing that is
certainly leading on that front we doing
the president's about to go to 1 Osiris
and meet with all the leaders of the
world's industrialized nations and
development nations as well it's not
such a great opportunity for him to sit
at the table and say folks this is what
my administration just reported this is
the time that we ought to act in concert
to prevent what my administration is
forecast to call once again we think
that this is the most extreme version
and it's not based on facts it's based
on it's not data-driven we'd like to see
something that is more data-driven it's
based on modeling which is extremely
hard to do yeah not data-driven total
jokes
so let's now put up the graphics that
popped up on screen when Sarah Huckabee
Sanders and and this the the
freeze-frame we have is just just
priceless when she started lying
CNN simply presented some facts like for
example this climate change report
involved 300 scientists and 13 federal
agencies so Donald Trump and Sarah
Huckabee Sanders are saying that the 300
scientists and 13 federal agencies that
did this are wrong they also point out
that the co-author was not paid for the
report that's another lie that started
being floated and they also pointed out
even though Sarah Huckabee Sanders is
saying that this was extreme and this
was not the the the the most accurate
assessment of the data that's out there
that indeed the report was open for
review and transparency before
publishing in fact it was peer-reviewed
this is what we need okay now I know
lots of Trumpets will say the
fact-checking is fake news it's biased
media screw them they're gonna say that
either way they've been saying it for
two years without CNN simply putting up
uncontroversial facts on the screen so
do it
that's what CNN did now meanwhile MSNBC
took a different approach they simply
ignored the entire press briefing which
I also think is fantastic they didn't
air Larry Kudlow came out first and
talked about how great the economy is
despite GM and Ford laying off
15% of their employees as I told you
yesterday MSNBC didn't air it John
Bolton came out and said he didn't
listen to the audio tape of Jamaal
khashoggi being killed because he
doesn't speak Arabic or some other
nonsense MSNBC didn't air that instead
MSNBC reported actual news instead of
propaganda lies from the administration
MSNBC when Sarah Huckabee Sanders was
lying and Bolton was lying and and they
were all out there lying they did a
story about General Motors they did a
story about trade they did a story about
US workers they reported on this
Guardian report about Paul Manafort
which were going to talk about later on
in the show they talked about the Senate
election in Mississippi were
unfortunately a racist Republican was
reelected and then if something actually
newsworthy happens during the briefing
they can report on it they can even
report on it minutes later after it
happens but they don't have to present
this endless propaganda platform to
their audience I think that this is
fantastic Pat the media should have
adopted either of these approaches a
long time ago fact-checking
or not airing it and then reporting on
what's new newsworthy later this is a
level of dystopian dissonance that we
are experiencing here and news outlets
can easily put a three or four minute
delay on these and so that they have
three or four minutes to fact-check
what's being said this is fantastic and
I congratulate them it sounds to me like
you like the CNN strategy the most so
much so I'm actually worried about you
starting to do this to me like when I
start rambling and going off-the-cuff
going off script you may say like will
David Pakman show facts first come up
over here as a graphic with like a list
of points debunking what I say yeah I
think that that would be a good idea
because that way when people write in
and they say David you know Pat said
something that was absolutely and
completely atrocious you really should
have immediately fact-checked him and
sometimes it's like well listen I don't
want to derail the show I don't want to
insult Pat if we just had a running
commentary of Corrections of Pat on the
side of the screen I think that that's a
really good idea we might just have to
hire someone to do that well I think we
are hiring now right
so that could just be the whole time so
listen yes if Fox News were to do this
their own fact checks would be
ridiculous
but they're already lying anyway and
these other outlets may actually reach
people by doing it so this is good I
hope that the media is actually now
starting to grow a backbone and that
they're going to do this regularly if
you think this is a bad idea
okay I want to hear from you why don't
you like this follow me on instagram at
david pakman follow the show at david
pakman show one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll have free access to
courses on music art photography
business computer programming cooking
meditation and everything in between I
think you'll have no problem finding
courses that are perfect for you
just took a really great class on
graphic design which I know nothing
about but I'm trying to learn our show
is giving you two entire months of
totally free access to every course
Skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video you'll have
two months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share that passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
10 bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of
Skillshare but hurry it's only available
to the first 500 who sign up